[Musik]
schwedische forscher sind so
pessimistisch wie nie klimaveränderungen
artensterben
militärische konflikte hungersnöte das
ist ein zeitalter der risiken sagen sie
und bei mir ist als gastgeber herzlich
begrüße professor maria göbel sie sind
nachhaltigkeits forscherin
angesichts dieser risiken die wir jetzt
noch einmal zitiert bekommen muss man da
nicht eigentlich zu handtuch schmeißen
auch überhaupt gar keinen fall jetzt ist
ja der entscheidende moment für welche
zukunft wollen wir uns einsetzen und ich
bin dafür das handtuch um heiß zu
wickeln los jetzt kommen aber noch dinge
hinzu wie populismus nationalismus das
sind dinge die sich ausbreiten um die
welt herum in politischen teilweise
diktaturen da kommen also nochmal
politische risiken hinzu die in den 90er
jahren so stark nicht ausgeprägt waren
wie wollen wir das denn hinbekommen das
eine und das andere
zusammenzubringen und zu lösen
kooperation ist der neue realismus und
das ist für mich vielleicht auch einer
der worte oder der aussagen die wir
nehmen sollten wenn wir die zeitenwende
versuchen zu verstehen weil es geht
natürlich darum einmal zu sagen nein das
sind inakzeptable aktivitäten dort
stattfindet etwas dagegenzusetzen und
trotzdem brauchen wir den raum und die
möglichkeit dass vor denken von was
könnten kooperationsstrukturen in der
zukunft sein
kooperation bedeutet aber das sind zwei
oder mehrere die haben ein ziel oder die
müssen zumindest eine gewisse einigkeit
erzielen über dieses ziel und genau das
ist ja im augenblick das ganz große
problem was wir haben auf der welt wir
alle wissen mehr oder weniger um die
umstände in denen wir leben und auf das
was kommen kann bei der klimaveränderung
etwa bei hunger et cetera also ist der
psychologie kennen wir das sehr unsicher
wird dann habe ich entweder die
möglichkeiten mich zurück zu orientieren
und sicherheit in etwas gewohntem zu
suchen da sind wir sehr gut drin das
haben wir ja auch gesehen mit dem
beschwören zurück zur normalität dabei
wussten auch schon vor corona dass das
nicht sehr normal ist sondern auch da
schon ja hoch risikoreich es ist wie wir
unsere weltwirtschaft entwickeln und die
andere möglichkeit ist zu sagen wie
schaffe ich es jetzt den schritt nach
vorne zu suchen und das ist ja das für
die transformations- forschung steht
würde ich sagen wir lassen ein
bestimmtes system das eine zeitlang uns
gut gedient hat los dass fossile energie
system wäre so 1 und gehen jetzt
wirklich mit allem was wir haben in ein
erneuerbares energiesystem rein obwohl
das gelingt oder nicht hängt natürlich
sehr stark von interessen ab von macht
ab aber auch von geschichten die wir uns
erzählen und zumindest auch die farbe zu
zeigen wie es gehen könnte und ich finde
das sehen wir ja live und in farbe den
ganzen tag dieses ringen darum geht
jetzt die investition wieder in öl und
gas oder schaffen wir das tatsächlich
diesem fahrtrichtung erneuerbare als den
dominanten zu halten oder wie seht ihr
da eine ganz großen zwickmühle auf der
einen seite wissen wir dass wir davon
weg müssen dass wir von gas von öl von
kohle weg müssen jetzt habe aber eine
ganz kritische situation durch den
ukrainer krieg wir haben plötzlich
weniger rohstoffe zur verfügung weniger
energie zur verfügung und jetzt gerade
mein sohn panik modus habe ich den
eindruck jetzt müssen wir ganz schnell
reagieren und gehen dann doch wieder auf
die alten sachen zurück genau und da
wäre es eben auch wichtig ruhe zu
bewahren und zu sagen also ich glaube
gerade in unseren reichen gesellschaften
wäre das auch wichtig wenn wir zu hören
der wohlstand wird nicht zu halten sein
und die lieferketten implodieren alle zu
sagen wir haben ein sehr hohes niveau
von dem wir starten hier wird nicht
morgen das licht ausgehen und hier wird
auch niemand verhungern das geht in
anderen ländern ganz anders zu und
deshalb finde ich es sehr wichtig und es
hat mir wahnsinnig gefehlt in der ganzen
debatte zu sagen wie können wir dann
auch mal was einsparen es war ganz
schwer sich da hin zu robben überhaupt
sagen zu können wie wäre es mal das
thermostat 23 grad runter zu stellen wie
wäre es mal das auto stehen zu lassen
stattdessen machen jetzt wieder
tankpauschalen anstatt die preise wirken
zu lassen sind sich inzwischen auch alle
ökonomen ökonomen einig und die andere
sache wäre eben auch zu gucken
getreideversorgung wollen wir jetzt
weiter dann ganz viel getreide in
tierbestände stecken oder wollen wir
dann sagen wir machen großes grillfest
und haben dann aber getreidebestände die
direkt am menschen weiterreichen können
also wir haben ja auch möglichkeit
innerhalb des systems was wir geschaffen
haben versorgungssicherheit zu halten
ohne dass es jemandem schlecht geht wir
müssen ein paar gewohnheiten loslassen
bleiben wir mal gerade bei der energie
und auch so wenn wir mal bei der
umstellung auf alternative energie sie
haben diesen green deal der europäischen
kommission begrüßt da geht es darum aus
dem co2 raus zu gehen oder aus dem
ausschuss des co2 rauszugehen jetzt ist
das beschleunigt worden durch den
ukraine krieg jetzt gibt es einen
repower eu das heißt nichts anderes als
dass man sehr schnell sparen muss auf
alternative energien gehen muss und im
zweifelsfall auch die quellen woanders
suchen muss kommen wir damit schneller
voran
also im prinzip ist auch ein
beschleuniger natürlich nur weil jetzt
also für leute die immer aus der öko
ecke argumentieren sollten und weil sie
umweltprobleme analysiert haben ist das
natürlich genau das was wir immer
versucht haben zu thematisieren
ökologisch ist nicht weich ist nicht
grün ist nicht irgendwie von den
menschen getrennt sondern ist das
grundlegende mit dem unsere wirtschaft
läuft und damit eben menschliche
sicherheit auch
gewährleistet werden kann und deshalb
sind solche auseinandersetzungen um
rohstoffe die auch nichts anderes sind
als teil von dem was wir ökologische
systeme nennen dass wir es ihnen
rausgenommen haben eben wahnsinnig
wichtig auch zu erhalten und langfristig
zu schützen und deshalb ist es jetzt wo
wir auf einmal sehen wo vielleicht ist
sicherheit und ökologie und
versorgungssicherheit und ein bisschen
weniger oder anders gestalten näher
aneinander gerückt ist das eine riesige
chance auch aus den vorherigen lagern
zusammen zu finden die sich da politisch
sehr bekriegt haben also wieso ist ein
thema wie energie immer noch ein grünes
thema ich bitte alle parteien darum
wirklich ganz klar zu verstehen dass das
ein gesellschaftsthemen und das ist eine
chance aber es ist auch ein neues
problem was da auftaucht unser
wirtschaftsminister habe gesagt ich
werde das was uns jetzt den ersatz
bringt zum beispiel beim gas das
flüssiggas das werde ich beschleunigen
indem ich ganz schnell die möglichkeit
schaffe deutschland helfen mit gas zu
versorgen mit terminals zu versorgen
planung muss ganz ganz schnell gehen und
da muss auch im zweifelsfall die umwelt
ein bisschen leiden also wir kommen ja
doch in diesem konflikt ja ich glaube
die sache wäre noch mal genauer zu
suchen weil es gibt ja auch
möglichkeiten zu sagen wie schaffen wir
das relativ ressourcenschonend oder auch
tierschutz und es gibt auch die
möglichkeit zu sagen wir machen erstmal
schwimmende tanne das ist jetzt die ganz
wichtige frage das hat man bei allen
krisenbekämpfung schaffen wir das
kurzfristig zu stabilisieren und
trotzdem nicht in die pfade wieder ein
zu zementieren die wir eigentlich lassen
wollten weil lng das haben wir vorher
auch fracking gas genannt ist keine
besonders umweltfreundliches ist
schädlicher als das gas aus sibirien im
zweifel so also wir sollten jetzt nicht
auf einmal einen anderen namen bekommen
hat und verfügbar ist sagen das ist toll
das behalten wir jetzt sondern das
sollte eine temporäre zwischenlösung
tatsächlich sagen wir immer von gas als
brückentechnologie scope gesprochen aber
es politisch nie so konsequent gesetzt
das war ja taxonomie auf der eu ebene
genau auch eine frage bleibt das ein
nachhaltiges investment oder muss man
sagen es ist jetzt eben eine
übergangsphase aber es muss die klare
ansage aus der politik sein dass das
keine option mehr ist und wir sehen ja
gerade wie die investments auch von den
ölkonzernen die nach draußen ganz tolle
per bus schüren schreiben sich primär
wieder in richtung öl und gas
orientieren und das ist ein rebound
effekt in richtung des alten systems den
wir uns nicht leisten können aber dann
muss man auch die menschen davon
überzeugen dass wir jetzt nicht nur in
einer krise sind sondern dass wir uns
auch grundsätzlich umstellen müssen das
ist ja das was sie in ihrem bestseller
auch beschrieben haben die welt neu
denken heißt auch mal über alternativen
nachzudenken anders zu leben ist das
nicht sehr viel verlangt wenn wir sehen
wie menschen darauf reagiert haben in
der pandemie etwa in eine völlig neue
lebenssituation geworfen zu werden
also ich möchte zwei punkte das eine ist
natürlich ob irgendwas tut also zumutbar
ist oder nicht das ist ja nicht das was
eine wissenschaftlerin entscheidet aber
wenn wir aus der wissenschaft immer
wieder prognosen machen können sie sagen
es ist sowohl ökonomisch als auch
technologisch möglich es ist eine
gesellschaftliche herausforderung ab wir
schaffen kann also kein umweltproblem
habe kein ökonomisches kann ökologisch
islam ein gesellschaftsproblem dann ist
es doch unseren job immer wieder
aufzuzeigen wie es auch anders gehen
könnte ob die gesellschaft das will oder
nicht ist nicht aufgabe der wissenschaft
gleichzeitig glaube ich dass es ganz
ganz zentrales auch zu sagen es gibt
doch viele dinge dazu zu gewinnen und
auch viele dinge mal sein zu lassen von
dem ich vielleicht schon länger und
unwohlsein hatten tierhaltung ist ja nur
so eine sache also wir haben so etwas
normalisiert in einem anspruch auf eine
bestimmte form von fleisch konsum von
der man sich ja durchaus fragen könnte
warum wir das für einen zivilisatorisch
aufgeklärt das land in ordnung ist
sowohl mit dem die arbeitsbedingungen
sind aber auch in den tieren umgegangen
wird und sagen wir nehmen das jemand mal
zum anlass und machen einfach gesunde
ernährung und deshalb sind ja neue
akteure wie jetzt zum beispiel aus der
gesundheit zu kleine terry haus oder
planetary die sagen wir können ökologie
und menschliches wohlergehen sehr viel
besser zusammenbringen wenn wir einfach
uns anders ernähren und das ist weder
eine grundrechts frage die auf dem
schirm liegt dann eine gewohnheit frage
und wir haben uns ganz lange zeit ja
anders ernährt und in anderen teilen der
welt ernähren wir uns immer noch sehr
viel fleisch ärmer und es wäre besser
für unsere gesundheit und das sind so
momente wo ich endlich das ja aber jetzt
nicht rauslassen dass ich sage ich bin
wissenschaftlerin und ich lege das
einfach nur auf dem tisch und dann
müssen die anderen entscheiden diese
diskussion halten wir zweieinhalb jahre
lang in der pandemie da haben alle
virologen da gesessen habe wir können
das nicht entscheidend da sind die
zahlen hier sind die zahlen entscheidet
man und die politik war in teilen
überfordert und ich habe den eindruck im
augenblick erleben wir ähnliches was
diese risiken anbetrifft weil wir auch
unter einem wirklichen panik modus
agieren zurzeit sie müssen die menschen
überzeugen wie kann denn das gelingen
wenn man neu denken will aber es ist ja
auch nicht so schwer also
jeder von uns hat ihren eigenen
burghauner ich habe jetzt sehr viel auch
experimentiert dass ich mit
kulturschaffenden zusammengearbeitet
habe dass wir versuchen das auf die
bühne zu bringen dass sie die lebensstil
frage als etwas positiv ist etwas neu
dazu zu gewinnen dass sich rückbesinnen
das aber eben natürlich auch mit neuen
technologien richtig mit einem
innovations- diskurs zu verbinden das
ist na also wenn wir zum beispiel gucken
wie der jetzt mit fermentation oder
neuen protein basen experimentierte man
fleischgeschmack bekommen kann ohne dass
das die welt retten muss ist das ein
integraler bestandteil und diese
innovations- idee merke ich gerade bei
jüngeren leuten bei start-ups die sehr
grün orientiert und haben wir in berlin
beispielsweise sehr viel mehr als
woanders oder auch bauern bei und die
sagen natürlich können wir gerne
aufhören die moore trocken zu legen und
zu bewirtschaften aber wenn die und
agrarsubventionen uns weiterhin sagen
ihr kriegt aber keine subventionen mehr
wenn es wieder vernässt soll wenn es
barak hat dann sind das natürlich dort
den rahmenbedingungen politik die den
menschen es leichter machen diese
umdenken reihe auch im handeln
umzusetzen oder schwerer und wann immer
ich mit menschen direkt sprechen krise
unternehmer innen außen mittelstand die
sich selbst darüber beschweren dass der
standard von dem was sie anbieten können
die qualität der produkte runtergeht
weil der preiskampf so brutal ist dann
ist das doch der moment wo ich sagen
muss die qualität sinkt in unserem land
durch einen markt system das nicht mehr
funktioniert im sinne der sicherung der
besten qualität und dieses zusammenspiel
und diesen druck aber auch diese diese
öffentliche meinung gegen eine ich habe
manchmal den angenehm medien werden die
leute immer herangezogen die dritte
person gibt es irgend beleuchte auf dem
set der dringend fleisch essen muss aber
wenn man in rumpf ragt ein beleuchtern
gibt es überhaupt gar nicht so viele die
das sagen also wir müssen noch mal
anfangen wirklich zuzuhören ich habe den
eindruck wir werden die beleuchteten
tragen aber das verlangen sie in einer
lage in der wir eine inflation von über
sieben prozent haben in der sich viele
leute diese so also wirklich sorgen
machen wie sieht eigentlich die
heizkostenrechnung aus die nächste wie
kann ich die denn bezahlen da beißt sich
die sache doch wieder in den schwanz in
dem ich nämlich von den leuten eine
umstellung zu einem zeitpunkt verlange
zudem dass besonders schwer ist für
viele und das sind nicht wenige
aber da möchte ich auch noch mal trennen
also das ist jetzt wenn ich geld sorgen
habe dass das eine wirklich unangenehme
situation ist gerade wenn ich mich dann
noch in der situation fühle dass mir
selbst die kontrolle nicht obliegt das
zu ändern weil ich angewiesen bin
bekomme ich zahlungen vom staat weil man
lohn wird sich ja jetzt nicht
kurzfristig verändern lassen das ist
aber etwas anderes als kreativität die
freigesetzt werden kann durch eine
begrenzung und das haben wir in der
korona krise ja durchaus auch gesehen
dass in dem moment wo etwas einfach
nicht mehr funktionierte menschen sehr
kreativ geworden sind sagen wir schaffen
es denn trotzdem gerade im ersten block
dann hatten wir unheimlich viele
experimente wie den hackathon wir gegen
virus oder eben viele lokale initiativen
die geschaut haben wie kriegen sie das
hier mit dem einkaufen für die älteren
personen wie können wir uns gegenseitig
unterstützen also dass begrenzung
kreativität freisetzt das eine dass ich
angst habe ob ich überhaupt noch
ausreichend mitmachen kann das ist
natürlich eine andere frage und wenn die
sehr zusammenkommen wird schwer und
trotzdem glaube ich dass die kreativität
erhalten ein übel aber dann fällt ihnen
doch quasi die politik in den rücken
denn das was sie verlangen von den
menschen ist für manche leicht für
manche nicht so leicht in der umstellung
das sind aber zwei gruppen die an die
tankstelle fahren und deren benzinpreis
gleicht subventioniert wird das kann
doch nicht sein
ja die debatte über gießkanne und wie
kann man differenzieren ist eine
schwierige und wir haben das ja gesehen
auch unter der kroner pandemie einige
unternehmen haben sich wahnsinnig gut
angepasst bei den theatern fand ich es
ganz eindrücklich an jahren ganz tolle
sitz konzepte gehabt wie man das
wirklich schaffen kann andere haben
nicht viel gemacht und dann kamen die
schließung und haben wieder alle
getroffen inklusive derer die versucht
haben die lösung nach vorne zu bringen
die unter der krise funktionieren
könnten das heißt das ausmaß an
differenzierung von maßnahmen das die
möglichst dort landen wo die
veränderungsbereitschaft am geringsten
ist oder natürlich der puffer am größten
ist was tragen zu können ist immer eine
herausforderung und wir sehen dass wir
sehr häufig bei der gießkanne gelandet
sind und ich glaube da ist es ganz
wichtig jetzt auch hinzuschauen dass sie
wirklich dafür sorgen dass diejenigen
die am meisten betroffen wurden und die
am wenigsten puffer haben doch nochmal
besser gestellt werden in der nächsten
denn es war schwierig sein demjenigen
der die tankstelle fährt und er sagt ich
muss zu meinem arbeitsplatz fahren und
ich muss jetzt deutlich mehr bezahlen
und es steht neben am ganz ganz großen
auto einem ganz ganz teuren 150.000 euro
auto was genau dasselbe an subventionen
bekommt wie der kleine wagen der daneben
steht das kann doch nicht sein wie kann
denn die politik so falsch in die
richtung laufen da bin ich ja die
falsche ansprechen
sie sind mal berater im beirat der für
die beratung der bundesregierung gewesen
also sie haben ja ständig kontakt mit
der politik warum läuft das denn so
schief
ich kann nur ein paar der argumente
wiederholen und das waren genau
diejenigen wenn immer ich ausnahmeregeln
mache wird jemand die in frage stellen
und wenn ich eine regel für alle mache
dann ist das das gerechteste obwohl man
dann natürlich jedes mal die bassline
vergisst deshalb ist jetzt die debatte
darum einfach so die mehrwertsteuer zu
senken genau wieder eine von dem wir
sagen ist naja es wieder nicht
differenziert wenigstens sollten
vielleicht nachdem herbert stocker
fleischprodukte hoch machen pflanzliche
produkte runter also das wird
tatsächlich ein bisschen eine
lenkungswirkung haben dahingehend was
sind die nachhaltigen lösungen aber im
prinzip ich weiß nicht was genau die
koalitionsgespräche sind ich habe eine
vorstellung davon wo welche positionen
stärker sind weil ich glaube dass wir
schon auch eine meinung in der koalition
haben die sagt es könnte auch gestufter
laufen und man hat ja
einkommensnachweise und könnte das daran
orientieren andere sozialhilfeleistungen
werden ja auch daran orientiert ich will
trotzdem noch mal zur politik zurück war
mir jetzt einen wirtschaftsminister dem
anzusehen ist nun anzumerken ist dass er
wirklich um eine lösung ring dass ihm
das auch persönlich große probleme
bereitet in dieser wirklich schwierigen
situation jetzt entscheidungen zu fällen
er kämpft sozusagen damit aber er kämpft
teilweise ja auch gegen windmühlen weil
er nach katar fahren muss um darum zu
betteln dass man dort das gas bekommt
was wir aus russland nicht mehr haben
wollen wie stark ist denn politik aus
ihrer erfahrung in dieser
zwangssituation
naja ich für mich war vielleicht der
eindruck war also eindrucksvollste
moment zu merken wie stark
oder wie groß der unterschied ist ob die
politik reagiert auf eine
schocksituation oder ob sie präventiv
versucht zu agieren und das ist eine
sache die wir auch schon lange
beschreiben kann auf der forschung dass
dieses antipathie 'we also
vorausschauende handeln dass langfristig
orientierte handeln sehr schwer ist dass
er erst in dem moment ist legitimiert
bekommen wenn die krise eigentlich schon
da ist und das hat man sehr deutlich
gemerkt als er habe ich sehr
herausgefordert war warum machen sie das
nicht mit dem gas embargo das war eine
zeitlang sehr hoher druck und er gesagt
hat sie müssen doch verstehen dass es
ein fundamentaler unterschied in der
akzeptanz durch die bevölkerung ist wenn
ich das tue weil er putin sowieso den
gashahn zugedreht hat oder wenn ich sage
wir haben das durchgerechnet das geht
und ich treffe diese entscheidung und
bin dann für alle die konsequenzen aus
meiner entscheidung heraus
verantwortlich und das ist ein teil des
problems dass ein großes dilemma weshalb
uns dass langfristig orientierte
regieren schwer fällt ich glaube das
wäre gut das zu thematisieren also
hatten dass prävention spa dogs ja auch
in der kroner krise er ist in dem moment
wo die fallzahlen wieder hochgefahren
sind wo die wetten wieder vollgelaufen
sind hieß es na ja vielleicht ist das
mit dem freedom day doch nicht so eine
gute idee wäre natürlich all diejenigen
die sich mit exponential funktionen
spricht dieser beschleunigten kurve
auskennen gesagt haben jetzt handeln
sonst und das ist glaube ich etwas was
wir sehr viel stärker in die debatte
einbringen sollten und vielleicht sogar
institutionalisieren sollten um sondern
politik zu helfen das zentrale thema
eigentlich ist er die verschmelzung der
interessen von umwelt und wirtschaft in
welcher phase befinden wir uns deine
morgen
sind wir da ein stück voran gekommen wir
haben ja schon mal über ihr buch
gesprochen
das gefühl in den letzten zwei drei
jahren ist das besser geworden absolut
also ich konnte natürlich darauf an mit
wem man spricht aber wir sehen in ganz
ganz vielen unternehmen dass die
personen die dort in
entscheidungspositionen sagen wir haben
es verstanden
das bedeutet ziemliche disruption in
unserem geschäftsmodell das schaffen wir
nicht allein wir brauchen die begleitung
der politik und wir brauchen aber auch
ja mitstreiter innen die das
thematisieren also da in der forschung
ist das immer dieser auseinandersetzung
wenn das die pioniere die schon etwas
neues machen die verraten wollen und
dann gibt es natürlich ein anteil die in
kamenz nennen die sich die gut
situierten im aktuellen status quo die
haben vielleicht nicht so ein interesse
dass sich schnell was verändert oder im
zweifel auch lieber gar nicht weil sie
können ja unseren spielraum auch wieder
vergrößern wenn wir die ökosysteme
aufbauen wenn wir sagen wir machen sie
resident gegen den klimawandel wir
schützen die biodiversität also wir
haben ja durch die option wirtschaften
anders zu gestalten auch sehr viele
möglichkeiten unseren
gestaltungsfreiraum insgesamt wieder zu
erhöhen und diese denkt ist glaube ich
wichtig um aus dieser sorge heraus zu
kommen
trotzdem ist natürlich die lage eine
besonders schwierige weil wir in vielen
ländern den eindruck haben dass doch
menschen als politiker agieren die das
gar nicht interessiert im gegenteil die
sogar dem zuwider laufen da muss man
nicht viele oder kann man viele länder
zitieren ob das brasilien ist oder
russland oder andere länder
trotzdem muss man ja sie haben von der
kooperation gesprochen
zusammenkommen weil das ein weltweites
problem ist der klimawandel weil das
artensterben ein weltweites problem ist
haben sie die hoffnung auch im hinblick
auf ihre beiden töchter dass man das in
den nächsten jahrzehnten hinbekommt muss
ja auf jeden fall alles geben und ich
finde man kann einmal sehr stark auf das
gucken was gerade schwierig ist sind wir
auch gewohnt weil das tendenziell den
nachrichtenwert ausmacht die
schlagzeilen wir können aber auch und
das ist vielleicht das dankbare meinen
job ich betrete wahnsinnige zuschriften
von menschen die längst auf dem weg sind
und dann sind das unterschiedlichste
initiativen also jetzt politisch bedacht
haben wir die klima klubs ja
beispielsweise als eine idee oder das
jetzt vielleicht einfach ein öl embargo
beschlossen wird selbst wenn gar nicht
mitmachen wird also es gibt ja immer
mehr wie eben auch die neuen
verbandsstrukturen der unternehmen die
wollen die sich vielleicht mal abspalten
dass es mich ein sektor ist dann die die
wollen und dann können ja die die für
die vergangenheit stehen auch gerne
weiter da stehen aber im zweifel müssen
sie halt dann und demokratischen der
andere richtung orientiert wir sehen
neue initiativen aus zivilgesellschaft
aus stiftungen wissenschaft jetzt haben
eine agora agrana agora industrie agora
energiewende das heißt da passiert ja
ganz viel aus der gesellschaft heraus
dass aufklärend wirken möchte und auf
die politik hin empfehlungen anbieten
möchte weil sie selbst merken dass das
in diesem paar parteipolitischen
geklüngel gar nicht so einfach ist aber
da passiert doch wahnsinnig viel ob das
ausreicht wie weit das trägt all diese
fragen paralysieren und ständig genauso
wie diese frage ist es nicht zu spät
schon für 1,5 grad ich wollte gott
fragen es gab ja immer wieder gesten und
gäste bei mir die ich gefragt habe an
welchem punkt sind wir da und die haben
dann im zweifelsfall auch gesagt na ja
wir haben einen bestimmten tippingpoint
und der ist in dem oder in dem fall auch
überschritten aus ihrer erfahrung aus
ihrer ansicht wo sind wir da
es ist wirklich an der zeit so viel wie
irgend möglich so schnell wie irgend
möglich zu tun aber das heißt nicht dass
der knopf an oder ausgeht also komplexer
systeme sind ja in einer ständigen
entwicklung und das heißt je schneller
ich eine eine exponentielle entwicklung
wie wir das bei dem freisetzen der
klimagase haben je schneller ich den
trend bremse umso kürzer ist der
bremsweg und nur mehr kann ich erhalten
je schneller ich den
biodiversitätsverlust bremse umso mehr
es noch da was sich dann wieder
regenerieren kann wann das genau stadt
von liedern die zusammenwirkung sind das
werden wir sehen aber wir haben doch
eigentlich ich finde die frage was ist
denn der umkehrschluss da machen uns
jetzt ein bier auf lehnen uns zurück und
warten bis das alles irgendwie sich bahn
bricht deswegen habe ich sie am anfang
gefragt flinte ins korn werfen
also solange ich sehe was in dieser
gesellschaft los ist so lange ich sehe
diese leute auf dem weg sind so lange
ich sehe was da auch an genialen
innovationen sich ausgedacht wird sobald
diese orientierung das ist die
zielorientierung das problem wollen wir
lösen von wir müssen immer mehr
bruttoinlandsprodukt schaffen wir können
die besten hochqualitativen produkte mit
dem geringsten ökologischen fußabdruck
für die höchste lebensqualität unserer
bevölkerung und den anderen teilen der
welt schaffen wenn das das
qualitätsmerkmal es auch dass wir hier
investieren innovieren kaufen und
politik machen dann ist das genau die
wirtschaft und die gesellschaft mit
denen wir dieses 1 1 der 100 hinbekommen
sie haben in einem interview gesagt sie
schätzen vielleicht gibt es ja auch sehr
konkrete zahlen darüber 20 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts sind quasi
negative folgen all der krisen die wir
im augenblick nicht bewältigen können
gerade auch der klimakrise das ist nur
menge geld die genaue zahl weiß ich
nicht also das wird so schön unter die
bretter gold gefasst na also dass so ein
bisschen im jahr schade dass das
aufgelaufen ist aber verdient hat
trotzdem jemand dran ich weiß nicht das
aatal wären sicherlich ein total
spannendes beispiel auch bei beyonce
könnte man ja mal fragen ist das jetzt
ein erfolg oder ist das eigentlich ein
drama dass so viel von der aktivität so
viel ressourcen auch genutzt werden
mussten um eine pandemie abzuwenden oder
einzudämmen von der wir sagen könnten
vielleicht hätten wir auch präventiv
mehr dafür tun können dass sie sich gar
nicht erst bei anbricht also deshalb ist
es so wichtig zu sagen die wirtschaft
kann wachsen oder kann weniger wachsen
was wichtig ist es was dahinter passiert
das ist das was uns das gefühl gibt sind
wir auf dem fortschrittlichen weg oder
nicht und diese diese differenzierung
einfacher zu machen dieses sichtbare zu
machen ich glaube das kann auch viel von
dir das sind die so viel kosten die
meisten fans investitionen gerade im
energiesystem wir wollen ja zukünftig
nicht mehr für die brennstoffe bezahlen
und wir wollen die ganzen
klimaschädlichen konsequenzen nicht
bezahlen das heißt jetzt viel geld in
die erneuerbaren zu stecken ist
mittelfristig die absolut ökonomische
idee und diese mittelfristig kite die
haben wir häufig der umbau kostet auch
wenn die ökosysteme der agrar der boden
wenn sich das wieder aufgebaut hat heute
die freunde freundinnen ich hab dir das
versuchen in der landwirtschaft die
kriegen keine kredite dafür mag
wirtschaftlich betrachtet ist das eine
risikostrategie die kostenintensiv ist
die brauchen philanthropisches geld die
ihnen die übergangsphase finanzieren und
dann kommt mehr die biodiversität rast
dann wird das wasser wieder besser
gespeichert dann können wir da auch sehr
gute erträge feiern wir können
vielleicht noch erneuerbare oben drauf
setzen die umbauphase ist die die schwer
ist wenn sie so ein bisschen das delta
zwischen heute und umbauphase sondern
die auch die überzeugung phase ist doch
die ihre freunde und freundinnen da gehe
ich mal davon aus dass sind aufgeklärte
menschen die sich mit den themen
beschäftigt haben der ein
grundsätzliches verständnis für
klimaschutz et cetera haben aber was ist
denn mit denen die sagen ja gott da wird
alles übertrieben das alles hat nicht so
furchtbar wie es beschrieben wird die
bösen medien treiben das immer in die
höhe
es ist und bleibt eine politische
aufgabe ich meine wir können das nicht
auf die einzelnen abwälzen das ist ja
auch totaler quatsch also erstens haben
wir eine gemeinwohl sich an der instanz
geschaffen weil andere von uns müsse als
anderes zu den ganzen tag außer sich um
gesetze und politik und informationen
für die politik schreibung zu besorgen
also genießen kinder erziehen wie andere
jobs nachgehen deshalb ist dass die
instanz an die wir ein stück weit dieser
verantwortung auch delegiert haben die
sollte uns möglichst transparent
darlegen warum sie wie handelt ich finde
dass wir in dieser neuen regierung eine
deutliche verbesserung dahingehend sehen
im vergleich zu dem was ich vorher
wahrgenommen habe dann haben wir ganz
viele aktuellen aus der gesellschaft ja
auch durch vorleben solche inspirieren
können und dann haben wir auch im
journalismus der sich in die richtung
orientiert zu zeigen also solution
oriente journalism oder positiver
journalismus auch mehrmals zu zeigen was
eigentlich schon passiert ich habe
riesen bildungsauftrag egal ob es jetzt
für die digitalisierung ist und ob es
für die nächste pandemie
oder eben das verständnis von den
zusammenhängen zwischen ökologie und
menschliche wohlergehen und guten
ökonomischer praxis aber das heißt ja
eigentlich auch werden für alle was zu
tun und deshalb ist das eben die
einladungen einfach loszulaufen wo ich
gerade bin in meinem system kann nicht
mit sicherheit dinge verändern aber wenn
wir immer da sitzen und sagen der macht
noch nicht die macht noch nicht darum
brauche ja auch nicht kommen wir machen
wird nicht helfen
wirklich helfen aber wie sieht dann das
aus was sie ihren töchtern hinterlassen
auf der erde
ach das ist glaskugel ich bin ja immer
noch auf der seite die sagt wir können
hass und wir haben ja auch soziale kitt
punkte also es gibt ja im moment wohl
wirklich dass sie die idee das ist
normalität kippt also das sind knapp ja
dass man diese moralischen revolution
genannt wo man auf einmal das gefühl hat
wie konnten wir das so lange so machen
oder auch am hudson hat er sehr viel zu
gerechtigkeit geforscht und im rückblick
ja es gibt ja auch irgendwann den moment
wo es kippt und ich glaube dass wir bei
einigen dieser punkte definitiv an
diesem moment sind und ich finde auch
einige dieser argumente die leute wollen
das nicht und sie sehen doch lassen sie
dann aufgefallen ist anekdotische
evidenz dieses narrativ die menschen
sind halt so und die wollen nicht das
kommt mir am allermeisten entgegen aus
bereichen wo sehr gut situierte menschen
sehr viel geld verdienen ich habe den
eindruck das ist ein sehr dankbares
motiv um sich selbst so ein bisschen
freizukaufen auf der frage warum bin ich
eigentlich so privilegiert und die
anderen nicht genau so die antwort darin
ich das nicht machen würde wird jemand
anders machen
wenn ich sehe dass das was ich mache
vielleicht nicht mehr intakt ist oder
mit dem zusammen passen dass meine ethik
mir eigentlich sagen würde dann bin ich
teil der verantwortung dafür zu sorgen
dass es strukturell in die richtung
kommen dass menschen nicht mehr so
handeln und an gereizt werden so zu
handeln und das meine ich mit der koppel
politiker ist on city nicht ach gott sei
dank sind ja noch schlimmer drauf als
ich dann habe ich als wieder ein
freifahrtschein das ist eine kulturelle
frage ich hab mir sehr viele bücher die
historisch menschliche geschichte
angucken gerade nochmal für das neue
buch angeschaut sie kommen alle zu dem
punkt entweder es wird eine kulturelle
veränderung geben
oder wir werden es eben auf eine
wahrscheinlich nicht sehr wünschenswerte
form erst mal wieder
das was wir im augenblick erleben ist
aber eine politische veränderung das was
dieser sieg report deutlich macht ist
dass wir eben nicht nur diese großen
schwierigen komplexen probleme haben
sondern auch diejenigen die es lösen
müssten in der politik eigentlich im
augenblick ganz egoistische ziele
verfolgen deshalb sage ich ja also in
jede institution ist das toll von
individuen ich kann eine entscheidung
für oder gegen etwas treffen die märkte
sind kein subjekt die märkte sind voll
von menschen die politik ist auch voll
von menschen und einige handeln so und
andere handeln so und deshalb ist ja
dass wichtige sich an denen zu
orientieren wo ich das gefühl habe die
wirken in eine ähnliche richtung gehe
ich im gemeinsamen haben wir mehrere
stellschrauben wenn ich das mal ich kann
gesetzgebung beeinflussen ich kann
natürlich die neuen innovationen
vorantreiben ich kann darüber aufklären
und als bürgermeister kann ich die leute
vielleicht begeisternd an einen tisch
bringen das meine ich noch mal mit
unseren unterschiedlichen work räumen
das wichtige ist ja dass wir uns darüber
verständigen worum geht es eigentlich wo
wollen wir hin wie können wir die key
performance indikatoren also spricht das
was wir messen das ist ja auch eine form
von geschichtserzählung sind wir auf
einem guten weg und sind wir nicht auf
einem guten weg wenn wir das da hin
anpassen dass wir sagen wir wollen zum
beispiel nachhaltigkeitsziele wirklich
erreichen und daraufhin wird die politik
auch bewertet anstatt auf tagtäglich
ändernde meinungsumfragen hat die auch
in anderen gestaltungsspielraum muss
sich aber auch anders rechtfertigen und
das sind ja alles möglichkeiten die wir
haben aber für die ergreifen oder nicht
steht und fällt mit menschen die diese
entscheidung treffen die das handtuch
nicht in den ring werfen ganz ziehen
dank der größe war mal waren dann
gelernt
[Musik]